We'll try and get an early catch and show what a transfer looks like, right?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Right, so, early.
It wasn't very good, but the premise being that if the catch is here and not here,
it'll just be bad.
Just delay your feet a second, yep.
It's a little space.
Yeah, yeah.
So, there's multiple things that are going wrong with all of us, right?
So, delaying your feet is definitely one.
So, that's a takeaway.
The other takeaway is really concentrate as you can to catch it here, latest here, so you can distribute a lot here, a lot up here, hopefully it hits yourself.
And just to be clear before we move on, what does late feet mean?
Like, what are we actually saying there?
You see the person in front of you, you see the back, you see their number, then you can advance.
If you're moving up too quickly, then you're not giving yourself time to catch a transfer, you're putting yourself under more pressure than you need.
Exactly right, exactly right.
And if I take...